[Müzik]
37 trilyon hücre Yetişkin bir insanın
vücudunda bulunan hücre sayısı ve bu 37
trilyon hücre
Bu yüzden farklı çeşit hücre çeşidine
tekabül ediyor
Peki biz yetişkinlikten zamanı geriye
doğru sararsak
başlangıç noktasına geri dönersek ne
görürüz buradaki hücreyi görürüz hepimiz
hayata bu şekilde başlıyoruz gördüğünüz
hücre yumurta ve spermin birleşmesi ile
oluşan Zigot Zigot embriyonik gelişim
sürecinde bölünüp farklı ulaşarak
Sonuçta bu bebeği oluşturuyor Peki nasıl
oluyor da tek bir hücre 200 farklı çeşit
hücreye dönüşebilme kapasitesine sahip
işte bu çok temel soru 20 senedir benim
Kafamı kurcalıyor
doktora çalışmalarımda ve doktora
sonrası çalışmalarımda burada araştırma
grubumla beraber bu sorunun cevabını
aramaya çalışıyoruz bir çözüm
oluşturabilmiş de değilseniz Aslında bu
soru öyle çok yeni bir soru değil uzun
yıllar boyunca yüzyıllarca bilim
insanlarını büyüleyen bir süreç gelişim
süreci ve öncelikli olarak felsefi
fikirler üretilmiş bu sürecin nasıl
olabileceği ile ilgili
mesela
zamanında
bilim camiasının büyük çoğunluğu
insanların
spermde var olan kıvrılmış Durmuş
minyatür bir insan insandan oluştuğunu
düşünüyorlarmış ve bu minyatür insan
döllenme sonrasında gelişim sürecinde
hiçbir değişime uğramadan sadece boyut
olarak büyüyerek bebeğe dönüştüğünü
düşünüyorlarmış şimdi bu size gülünç
geliyor tabii ki Ama yüzyıllarca kabul
görmüş bir görüş bu Tabi daha sonraki
çalışmalar bizlere gelişimin
farklılaşmamış bir hücreden kaynak
aldığını gösterdi bu farklılaşmamış
hücre Zamanla yavaş yavaş aşama aşama
değişerek 200 farklı çeşit hücreyi
oluşturabiliyor
bilimsel ve teknolojik gelişim bizim
embriyonik dönemi anlayabilmemiz
açısından çok faydalı oldu fakat
farklılaşmamış hücrenin İlk kimlik
oluşturma aşamalarını bunun en erken
aşamalarına dair bilgilerimiz henüz hala
çok yetersiz Çünkü bu kimlik belirleme
süreci Aslında Zigot oluşumundan hemen
sonraki zaman diliminde başlıyor Burada
gördüğünüz görüntüler zigottan sonraki
Sadece 5 günü içeriyor bu 5 gün
içerisinde hücreler bölünüyor hareket
ediyor şekil değiştiriyorlar ve Son
resimde gördüğünüz yapıyı oluşturuyorlar
bu yapının iç kısmında gördüğümüz
hücrelere Biz embriyonik kök hücreler
diyoruz
embriyonik kök hücreler gelişimin bundan
sonraki aşamalarında
farklılaşarak bütün hücre tiplerini
oluşturuyorlar ve yok oluyorlar ama
bunların iyi yanı biz bilim insanlarına
embriyonik gelişimi laboratuvar
ortamında çalışma olanağı sağlaması Biz
embriyonik kök hücreleri buradan izole
edip
laboratuvarda büyütüp erken gelişimi
gözlemleyebiliyoruz
embriyonik kök hücrelerin içi çok önemli
özelliği var hem kendilerini yenileyerek
daha fazla kök hücre oluşturabiliyorlar
hem de uygun koşullar sağlanırsa bütün
hücre çeşitlerini dönüşebilme
kapasitesine sahipler
Ben araştırma grubumla embriyonik kök
hücrelerin farklılaşma sürecini
etkileyen faktörler Üzerinde çalışıyorum
Böylelikle gelişimin erken safhalarını
daha iyi anlayabilmeyi istiyorum ve bu
bilgileri kullanarak alakalı
hastalıkların tedavisine seçenekler
sunabilmeyi amaçlıyor
embriyonik kök hücre farklılaşması
bir tepenin başından aşağı doğru
yuvarlanan bir bilye olarak
düşünülebilir Buna göre tepenin üst
noktasındaki
hücre henüz farklılaşmamış olan
embriyonik kök hücredir ve bu engebeli
tepenin devamında vadilerinde bulunan
hücreler ise özelleşmiş hücrelerdir
Mesela bir deri hücresi bir sinir
hücresi gibi düşünebilirsiniz
Şimdi bunu kendinizin Hayal etmesini
istiyorum engebeli bir tepenin üstünden
bilyeleri sırasıyla yuvarladığınızı
düşünün ve bu bilyeler bu vadilerden
birine yerleşerek aşağı doğru
yuvarlanırlar hücre farklılaşma süreci
de bu tarz bir süreç hızlı Olmuyor bir
sürü sırada karar mekanizmasının hassas
bir şekilde kontrolü ile sonuca
ulaşabildiğimiz bir süreç Ben aslında bu
kök hücre farklılaşmasını akademik
kariyere çok benzetiyorum Mesela
ortaokuldaki bir öğrenci için potansiyel
olarak her türlü meslek masaüstündedir
hepsini seçebilir Bir nevi kök hücre
olarak düşünebiliriz ortaokul
öğrencisini sonra liseye geldiği zaman
ilgi alanına göre belli bir alan seçer
mesela hukuk konusuna ilgisi yoksa o
zaman matematik fen alanında seçebilir E
tabii bu seçimle beraber
olabileceğim meslek listesi biraz
kısıtlanmış olur sonrasında üniversite
sınavına gireceği zamanda kendi bölümünü
belirler özelleşmenin en önemli
aşamasını kaydetmiş olur lisans
eğitimini tamamladığı zaman da daha
ilginç bulduğu alt alanlara yönelebilir
hücre farklılaşması da bu şekilde bir
sürü küçük kararın sonrasında ki
seçenekleri etkilemesiyle oluyor peki
Biz embriyonik kök hücreler hakkında
oldukça yüksek bilgiye sahibiz
özelleşmiş hücreleri de çok iyi
tanıyoruz bu başlangıçtaki ve bitişteki
hücreleri bilirsek biz bu iki noktayı
birbirine bağlayan farklılaşma
mekanizmasını tahmin edebilir miyiz
bu iş ne yazık ki o kadar kolay değil
bunu Ankara ile İstanbul arasındaki bir
gidiş yolu olarak düşünürsek burada size
sunduğum gibi birden fazla opsiyon
birden fazla seçenek var olabilir Ankara
ile İstanbul'u birbirine bağlayan üç
farklı yol görüyorsunuz bunlardan bir
tanesi daha hızlı görünüyor ama yol
boyunca yol çalışmaları var bir risk
oluşturabilir
Böylelikle bizim yapmaya çalıştığımız
embriyonik kök hücrelerin farklılaşma
sürecindeki bütün seçenekleri iyice
tanımlamak Böyle yaparak bir yolda
farklılaşma yolunda ilerleyen hücrenin
önünde ne gibi Engeller Var biz bu
engelleri kaldırabilir miyiz veya Yol
Nerede daralıyor Biz o yolu biraz
genişletebilir miyiz veya diyelim ki
yolun bir yönünde yanlış bir yöne sapma
olasılığı var Biz o yönü bloke edebilir
miyiz diye sorular soruyoruz ve bunları
anlamaya çalışıyoruz Eğer ki biz Bu
bilgiye ulaşabilirsek bu detayları
bilebilirsek hücreleri bir şekilde diğer
şekile bir çeşitten diğer çeşitte
belirlenebilir
takip edilebilir hızlı verimli ve
güvenli bir şekilde Götürebiliriz
şimdi Eminönü kök hücrelerin farklılaşma
potansiyelinin çok yüksek olduğundan
bahsettik O yüzden tıbbi açıdan da çok
değerli hücreler Bunlar
herhangi bir hasar ya da hastalık
durumunda embriyonik kök hücreler
istenilen özelleşmiş hücreye
farklılaştırılabilir ve hastaya
nakledilebilir Çok süper yalnız burada
çok büyük bir problem var
hiçbirinizin vücudunda yetişkin dönemde
embriyonik kök hücre bulunmuyor O zaman
nasıl yapacağız hasarlı ya da hastalıklı
dokuyu onarmak için elimizde ne gibi
seçenekler var Yakın zamanda 2006
yılında biz artık erişkin özelleşmiş
hücrelerden embriyonik kök hücrelere
benzer hücreleri oluşturma kapasitesine
sahip olduk bunu becerebiliyoruz artık
şimdi size biraz bundan bahsetmek
istiyorum
buraya girerken bir anekdottan
bahsedeceğim Şimdi ben lisansımı Bilkent
Üniversitesi'nde okudum ama o dönemde
Benim arkadaşlarımın büyük çoğunluğu
ODTÜ'de okuyordu Bilkent genelde daha
erken tatile girer Biz de tatile
girmişiz Ben de arkadaşlarımı görmek ve
kütüphanede çalışmak için kampüse
girmeye çalışıyorum Bunun ne kadar zor
olduğunu Eminim siz de biliyorsunuz
Tabii ki kapıdaki a1'deki güvenlik
görevlisiyle Çetin bir pazarlık
sürecindeyiz ve orada o
dönemin yapıldığı klonlamanın büyük bir
süksü olduğu dönem O yüzden insanlar ne
bileyim bir beş sene sonra insanın
klonlanabileceğini düşünüyorlar
güvenlik görevlisi bana şunu sordu Hangi
bölümde okuyorsun Ben böyle külah
biyoloji ve genetik bölümündeyim dedim
ve bana söylediği şey seni Kampüs'e
girişine İzin vereceğim yalnız tek bir
şartım var insanı klonlamayacaksın
Tamam söz veriyorum Kesinlikle
klonlamayacağım ve o sözü tuttum
Ama bu sözü tutmak Aslında bilim Dünyası
için çok kolay oldu çünkü
2006 yılında gerçekleştirilen bu buluş
bize artık insan klonlamasının yapılması
gerekliliğini ortadan kaldırdı Bunun
yerine artık biz erişkin dokulardan
yetişkinden alınan hücrelerden
embriyonik kök hücre potansiyeline sahip
hücreler elde edebiliyoruz Nasıl oluyor
bu şimdi özelleşmiş hücreler
biliyorsunuz kimliklerini kolay kolay
kaybetmezler yani bir kan hücresi Bir
sabah uyanıp Ben bugün sinir hücresi
gibi davranacağım ona karar verdim demez
ve Bu iyi bir şey aslında
ama biz Eğer bu özelleşmiş hücreleri
alırsak cebren ve hile ile embriyonik
kök hücreleri özgü bazı faktörleri
yüksek miktarda bu hücrelere verirsek
nadir de olsa bunun Altını çiziyorum
nadir de olsa bazı hücreler bu
kimliklerini kaybedip embriyonik kök
hücreye benzer hücrelere dönüşüyorlar
bunlara uyarılmış floropent kök hücre
diyoruz ve bu yöntemin adı yeniden
programlama yöntemi basit anlamıyla var
olan kimliği kaybetme yöntemi
uyarılmış kök hücreye dönüştükten sonra
ise Artık bunlar embriyonik kök hücre
gibi çok değişik hücre tiplerine
dönüştürülebiliyor Oradan sonra önü açık
bizim embriyonik kök hücre
farklılaşmasıyla öğrendiğimiz bilgiler
bu nadir yeniden programlama olayını
daha verimli hale getirmesi açısından
şifreler verebilir Bu bilgileri
uyarılmış kök hücre üretimini daha iyi
daha hızlı daha yüksek verimli bir
şekilde gerçekleştirmemize olanak
sağlayabilir Peki biz bu hücreleri nasıl
kullanıyoruz Bunun iki ayağı var hem
temel bilim ayağı hem de tıp ayağı ben
size ikisinden de kısaca bahsetmek
istiyorum şimdi bir rahatsızlığınız
olduğunda hastaneye gittiğinizde Doktor
bir teşhis koyuyor buradaki zorluk şu
Doktor teşhis koyuyor ama sizin
hastalığınızın teşhisten önceki kısmı
hakkında bir fikri yok yani sizin
vücudunuzla vücudunuzda sizin genetik
yapınızla o hastalık nasıl oluşmuş bu
konu hakkında hiçbir bilgimiz yok tabii
Bunu öğrenmek çok değerli Çünkü eğer biz
bunu bilirsek artık hastalığı tedavi
etmekle uğraşmayacağız hastalığı önleme
aşamasına geçeceğiz Öyle değil mi
uyarılmış kök hücreler bunun önünü
açıyor nasıl yapıyor hastadan aldığımız
özelleşmiş hücreler Bu bir deri
biyopsisinden olabilir kan hücreleri
olabilir hastalıklı doku ile alakası
olmasa bile herhangi bir özelleşmiş
hücreyi alıyoruz Bu yeniden programlama
yöntemiyle uyarılmış kök hücre
oluşturuyoruz ve bu uyarılmış kök hücre
hastanın genetik yapısına sahip
bu uyarılmış Kök hücreyi sonra yeniden
kimliklendiriyoruz bu sefer hastalıklı
dokudaki hücre tipini Mesela bir alt
timer hastasını düşünelim ondan
aldığımız kan hücrelerinden uyarılmış
kök hücreye oluşturuyoruz ve sonra
onları sinir hücresine dönüştürüyoruz
şimdi elimizde hastaya özgü hasarlı
sinir hücresi var bunu sağlıklı
bireylerin sinir hücreleriyle
karşılaştırarak o hastada ne hatalı
gitmiş ne sorun var
bulabiliriz Böylelikle uyarılmış kök
hücreler bize hastalıkların laboratuvar
ortamında modellenmesi şansını tanıyor
hastalıkların hastalık oluşum sürecini
anlamamızı sağlıyor aynı zamanda bu
kişiye özgü hücreleri kullanarak Biz
geniş ilaç taramaları yapabiliriz
Böylelikle kişiye Özgü tıp
yolunu açmış oluyoruz
Peki Tabii ki asıl amacımız burada
hastalığın tedavisi hastadan aldığımız
kan örnekleri ile oluşturduğumuz
uyarılmış kök hücre dediğim gibi aynı
genetik yapıya sahip Eğer genetik bir
hastalıktan bahsediyorsak dna'daki
hasarı mutasyonu bulduğumuz zaman bunu
sağlıklı bir bireyinkine dönüştürüp
farklılaştırıp hastaya nakletme
potansiyeline sahibiz
bu müthiş bir buluş müthiş bir yöntem ve
uyarılmış kök hücrelerin tarihi çok
fazla değil 2006 yılında ortaya çıktığı
için Fakat şu anda birçok hastalık için
uyarılmış kök hücre bazlı tedaviler
tedaviler için olan çalışmalar Öncül
klinik safhalarda
şu anda Henüz bir sağlık ya da ilaç
otoritesinin geniş kapsamlı kullanımına
onay verdiği uyarılmış kök hücre bazlı
tedavi bulunmamasına rağmen bazı deri
hastalıkları kalp krizi diyabet bazı
çeşit köylük
belli oluyor
bu bazı tedavilerin kullanımı üzerine
çok umut vadeden gelişmeler var bizim
embriyonik kök hücre farklılaşmasını
anlayarak bilim dünyasına kattığımız
bilgiler sonrasında uyarılmış kök
hücrelerin tedavide kullanılabilmesinde
önünü açacak diye umuyoruz
size hücrelerin kimlik oluşum sürecinden
ve bu kimliği değiştirmenin
yöntemlerinden bahsettim aslında burada
yaptığımız şey bir nevi hücrelere yaşam
koçluğu yapmak ve bunun da önemini
umuyorum şimdi Sizler de biraz daha fark
ettiniz teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]